NOT SCORING FIRST
AND YOU'RE NOT
STARTING ON TIME
SOMETIMES YOU TRY TO.
WILL PROVIDE SOME
BENEFIT FOR BOTH
CLUBS PLAYING AT
THIS RATE.S
JOHANSSON ON THE
PUCK FOR SEATTLE.
GIVES IT,
CROSS-ICE, TO
DEBRINCAT INS,
BY GOING TO THE . KENNY
APPRECIATE YOU
JOINING US.
THANK YOU SO
TO A GOAL.
KEITH: B
RIGHT AWAY.
HE STOPS IT AND THAT
ALLOWS MARC-ANDRE
FLEURY TO COME STAFF
DOWN THERE, JONES, .T BF
FOR JOHNSON.
PICK OFF BE BLACKHAWKS
CLEA
PUSHUPS.D OUT BY
MURPHY.
THTH KURASHEV AND
KANE.
OFF THE T
JOHANSSON. FRONT.
THE STICK INTO THE
AROUND.
KEPT IN THE ZONE BY
THE KRAKEN.
SCHWARTZ THROUGH THES T
SHOT.
SAVED, RIGHT OFF THE
ARE
KRAKEN.
HERE'S EBERLE.S ALL OF
THE MOMENTUM.
KEITH: HE DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE HE'S
LEY.
IT'S CLEARED TOWARD
THE EMPT WITH A LITTLE
HOHO